- Things can't go worse than that.
I'll sleep on the floor,
I'll sleep on the pavement.
I've never believed in super stardom,
I believe that if people like your work
which is your performance
in front of the camera,
that is what attracts them to you.
Everyone said that I was
making the biggest mistake
of my life by going into television.
If things happen
according to how you wish,
that's good, but if they
don't, that's even better.
There'll always be somebody
who's going to be younger,
better than you.
- He's an Indian actor who's
appeared in over 180 films
in a career that has
spanned over four decades.
He's widely regarded as
one of the most influential
and important figures in
Indian cinema history.
He was so dominant over
the Indian film market
in the '70's and '80's
that people called him
a one-man industry.
He's Amitabh Bachchan,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like the best.
And as always, if you hear something
that really is motivating
and inspiring to you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
(swoosh)
(dramatic music)
- I doubt if there's any
actor in the entire world,
with all due respects to Mr. De Niro,
when they haven't gone
ahead and done a film
and it hasn't turned out to be
the kind of film that
they believed it would be,
or it has been so incredibly bad
that it's just kind of
forgotten in their vision.
Sometimes we do films
because we believe in the
person who was going to make it.
Sometimes it's a gesture.
Sometimes it's your
own belief going wrong.
We all make mistakes,
and if they were mistakes, fine,
but I will not deride any
film that I have done.
I will stay with every
film that I have made.
And I will say that I had
a great time making them
irrespective of what
happened at the box office.
Failure is a part of
every human being's life.
To think that failure is never
ever going to come to you
is the first mistake.
It is bound to come some point in time,
even if you're riding
a huge wave of success.
I think it's important
that at the back of your
mind you should be weary
that tomorrow everything can go wrong.
Whenever I think like
this I immediately think,
"Okay, suppose I was to lose everything.
"What is the bottom line that
would keep me comfortable?"
So I go back to where I was born
and how I was brought home in a tonga
wrapped in a (mumbles), and I say,
"The worst is that things
can't go worse than that.
"I'll sleep on the floor.
"I'll sleep on the pavement."
So you look at the bottom line.
- And that makes you
feel it's not that bad?
That gives you strength?
- You feel that if you're
prepared for the worst.
A lot of people can say,
"Look, I can't do without
a house with 10 bedrooms."
Or, "I need two cars, and I need a phone."
Everyone has different priorities,
but I think that what's really,
what I feel is that I think
about the bottom line,
and when it isn't too
difficult to cope with
I feel very satisfied.
From there on you say,
"Okay, this is where I am.
"I have to move forward from here.
"This is the worst scenario,
and now I must move forward."
So every day you keep digging
away, digging at something,
poking at something,
and even if it's a centimeter
that you move forward,
at least you move forward.
I'm always reminded of an
incident of my father's.
We used to live in Delhi
at William and Crescent,
which is near (mumbles) house
where (mumbles) used to stay.
And at that time the diplomatic enclave,
which is now very, very habitated,
was just wilderness and wild jungle,
and he used to go for his
morning walk in that region.
And he used to leave
at 3:40 in the morning
and come back at 5, 6.
And he developed a taste for
looking at rocks on the road
and finding some kind of
an image or a figure in it.
And he would bring it home
and with just a stroke of a paintbrush
bring out the dimension,
or just leave the stone like that and say,
"Look, this looks like a bird,"
or, "This looks like a human,"
and he developed this thing.
One day he came back from his walk
and he woke me up, as he normally would,
at 6 in the morning and say,
"Can you just help me?
"I've got something which I cannot lift,
"so help me bring it in."
So I went to the gate
and there was a huge
boulder about this size.
And I said, "Look, you
can't possibly think
"that I can move this."
So we called about 10, 20 people,
and they pushed this huge boulder
and brought it into our veranda
where he wanted it to be put.
That dinner I asked him,
"Look, this is fine, but how
did this come up to the gate?"
So he said, "You know, I went for my walk.
"I saw this huge rock.
"I saw this shape in it, and I liked it
"and I wanted to move it."
So every day I go I move it
one inch and I come back.
In three months it's
landed up at the gate.
(applause)
So it's a great example
that if you just keep
pushing something every day,
it may look small,
but I think the important thing
is that you're moving forward.
And there is some amount of satisfaction
that you've done something
which is somewhere giving
you some satisfaction,
and that eventually you will bring
that huge boulder to its destiny.
I have never believed in superstardom.
I believe that if people like your work,
which is your performance
in front of the camera,
that is what attracts them to you.
I don't see any other medium being used
to attract audiences.
It's eventually your film, and
that's what's going to work.
You may have the greatest managers
and the greatest PR machines,
but unless you perform well
in front of the camera,
it's of no use.
- For 45 years he has
reflected and shaped society.
When he got angry, the nation got angry.
When he got injured, the
nation came to a standstill.
And now, when the common man of the nation
has taken to the streets of (mumbles)
he made (mumbles).
- What you said was more an instigation
by the people who write films,
and if credit has to be given
to the mood of the country at the moment
and how it is reflected in cinema,
you will have to credit
the writers of the time.
So if you felt that there
was a moment in the film
which talked about anger,
which talked about going
against the system,
wanting to fight alone,
then Salim-Javed who wrote
the script of Zanjeer
at that point of time
will have to be credited,
because they were the ones
that thought about it.
Many a times this question is posed to me,
but I'm merely another actor
who has just happened to be
lucky enough to get that role.
- You're not merely
anything, Mr. Bachchan.
- Yeah, right now I am.
There came a turning point
where mainly due to financial reasons
I got an offer from
television to host KBC,
which was the Hindi version
of Who Wants to Be a Millionaire?
And I took that job,
and I felt that that was
a savior in many respects,
because suddenly it gave me an opportunity
to interact with the people of the nation,
with the common man,
with people whom we knew
existed in our country
but we've never known their conditions.
It was a great eye opener for me
apart from the fact that
it was a novel experience
for me to be working on television.
Everyone said that I was making
the biggest mistake of my
life by going into television,
reducing myself from
a 70 millimeter screen
onto a 25 inch TV screen
felt was almost like reducing your stature
to 25 inches of a TV screen.
But there were compulsions,
and I went ahead and I'm
now in the 12th year of KBC.
I keep quoting my father all the time,
and I'm sure I've done
this millions of times.
One of the first things he taught me
was (speaks in Hindi),
if things happen according
to how you wish, that's good,
but if they don't, that's even better.
And I could never understand that.
And when I asked him he said,
"If they're not happening
according to your wish,
"they're happening according to the wish
"of some divine force,
"and that divine force will
never think ill about you,
"so you have to respect
that as being better."
So if things worked I said, "Fine."
If they didn't, I felt
that there was some kind of
divine force or divinity
that didn't want me to do that
and perhaps wait for another opportunity.
The other thing he told me was
when I was struggling a
lot in those times, I said,
(speaks in Hindi)
So he said, (speaks in Hindi).
I used to tell him life is a struggle.
And he used to say, "So
long as there is life
"there is going to be struggle."
I think if you accept this factor
that your life is never going to be easy,
something or the other is going to happen,
so rather than sit in some
kind of despondency on that
and be aware that tomorrow
is another challenge,
is another day,
which could turn out to be
profitable, which may not,
but eventually there will be another day
when you can start trying all over again.
- And then there was a lag in your career
for almost 10 to 15 years,
which is really the death of an actor,
because you joined politics,
then you made some bad decisions,
and you didn't really sign films,
and then suddenly you
were a middle aged actor.
What did you do to change
the rules of the game
that today you are sitting here?
- I think certain circumstances
are always at that point of time
where I was given to understand
that I didn't need to work anymore.
And I took a sabbatical
for a couple of years,
and now that I look back I
feel that that was a mistake
and I shouldn't have done that,
because a lot of water had
flown under the bridge so to say
during the time that I wasn't working.
It also teaches you
that you're never going to be the best,
you're never going to
be on top of the ladder.
There will always be somebody
who's going to be younger, better than you
who will take your place,
and this is quite common in sports
and in our profession as well.
It takes a bit of time to understand that.
I would be lying if I said that I
was not comfortable with it.
It was very discomforting,
because you suddenly find
that if you go into a public situation
you find greater attention being given
to the other person than yourself
when all along your career
you've been the center of attraction,
and it takes a while to understand that.
But I think that the
sooner you understand that
the better for you as an actor.
You're not going to be
able to be number one.
You're never going to be able to
attract the kind of commercials
or the public adulation,
and you just want to carry on working
because you enjoy the profession
without all these other tributaries
that get attached to it.
I look for challenges even
today, and even as I sit here
I hope that tomorrow as I start a new film
I will be able to look
at it as a challenge.
I'm still very nervous when I go there.
I feel that every new
opportunity that comes my way
needs to be looked at as
that one door that will open,
something which perhaps will
stop me from being bankrupt again,
and stop me from getting
back into that situation
where I had to plead
against all my debtors
to save me from this situation,
and that's how I look at it every day.
I hope that I can continue doing that,
because I don't want this sword,
this Damocles sword hanging on my head,
and therefore I continue
working so long as I can.
But yes, in the back of my mind
there will be those ugly
moments that plagued me,
and the fear of them recurring again
is perhaps what drives me every day.
- You've said this in the past
that you are really a director's actor,
that at the end of the day
you don't have an idea of the film,
but you absorb the director's
idea what he expects of you.
- I think that it's important for you
to leave the decision
making to one person.
I like to listen to one person on set,
and if he's the captain of the ship
I will do what he asks me to do,
because he has the visual,
and the sense, and the idea in his mind
of what he wants to make.
If you have the disagreement with him,
have the disagreement during the time
when he's narrating the script to you.
Have all your arguments and
discussions before that,
but once you come on set
I think it's only very
professional and ethical
to follow what the
director tells you to do.
- If this 71 year old Mr. Bachchan
could go back to the younger Amitabh
and hold his hand and say,
"Don't take this path, go here instead,"
at what moment would that be?
- I'd never say that,
because I think that whatever happened
I wouldn't want to change it.
I feel that many of the
mishaps, or the wrong decisions,
or the failures that I had
were great learning grounds for me.
I think I'm a lot wiser now.
No one is the ultimate person
as far as wisdom is concerned,
so I feel that I wouldn't
want to change anything
and just continue the way I'm going.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Faks Jilan asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did you learn from this video
that really resonated with you?
What point did you take home the most?
What changes are you going to make
in your life or your business
after watching this video?
Please leave in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Katherine Carini.
Katherine, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one
word is, much love guys.
I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)